FORMER HURRICANE -- WILL BE
TAKING THE PRACTICE TIME.
SATURDAY NIGHT IN NEW JERSEY --
HAD A NICE ASSIST IN ONE OF THE
SHOT RIGHT ON.
SHOT. BACK INTO THE
MARTINOOK'S PASS A LITTLE BIT -
CHECKING  SHIP THAT BEGAN WITH
ANDERSEN.
ANDERSEN -- FOUR ASSISTS ON THE
SEASON.
UP TO COLE BACK INTO THE
>> Tripp: THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE
SECOND PERIOD.
CAROLINA
SMITH -- NEW YORKTHE
GOAL LINE.
THAT CREATES THE WHOLE CHANCE.
JUST CANNOT TAKE A BREATH.IT ISO
WORTHY CHALLENGE.
YOU THINK K BOARDS.
AHO HAS A STEP.
TRYING TO CENTER CROSS IS PUCK
>> ON AS
BRENDAN SMITH USED THE BOARDS
THERE FOR AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIS CAPTAIN.
>>BUT WHAT
THEY SAY.WER PLAY
FOR THE CAROLINA HURRICANES.
>> Tripp: AND THE FACE
THE GOALSCORER FOR VEGAS.
SEND
>> Tripp: KEEPS LOOKING UP AT
THE CLOCK BUT HAS NOT LOCKED
ST TO THE RIGHT ME.
THREE ON THREE HOCKEY.
JORDAN STAAL WILL TAKE
STAAL WINS IT AND HE WILL HEAD
RIGHT TO  TO FIND TROCHECK.
JUST OUT OF REACH.
TROCHECK SOTO SAT DOWN.
GETS THE HE SCORES!